et je jouais aux jeux vidéo dans mon sous-sol.
En montant pour boire quelque chose,
j'ai regardé par la fenêtre
et j'ai réalisé que j'étais censé faire quelque chose.
Voici ce que j'ai vu.
Non, ce n'était pas le dîner familial en feu.
C'était mon projet de science. (Rires)
Il y avait plein de flammes,
de la fumée,
et il semblait que notre terrasse en bois allait prendre feu.
Immédiatement, j'ai commencé à crier.
Ma mère était paniquée,
mon père a accouru pour éteindre le feu
et, bien sûr, ma sœur a commencé à en faire une vidéo Snapchat.
(Rires)
Ce n'était que le début du projet de science de mon équipe.
Mon équipe était composée de moi et trois autres élèves
qui sont présents aujourd'hui.
Nous avons participé à la « FIRST LEGO League »,
une compétition internationale LEGO de robotique pour enfants,
et, en plus d'un jeu robotique,
nous avons aussi travaillé sur un autre projet de science.
Voici le projet sur lequel nous avons travaillé.
L'idée pour ce projet a été lancée quand, quelques mois plus tôt,
deux de mes coéquipiers ont voyagé en Amérique centrale
et ont vu des plages jonchées de Styrofoam
ou de polystyrène expansé.
A leur retour, ils nous en ont parlé
et nous avons réfléchi au fait que nous voyions du polystyrène au quotidien.
Vous avez un nouvel écran plat ?
Vous finissez avec un bloc de polystyrène plus gros que la télé.
Vous buvez une tasse de café ?
Ces gobelets en polystyrène vont s'accumuler.
Où vont tous ces objets après leur utilisation unique ?
Puisqu'il n'existe aucune bonne solution pour le polystyrène usagé,
la majorité finit à la décharge, dans les océans ou sur les plages,
nécessitant plus de 500 ans pour se dégrader.
Chaque année, les États-Unis produisent à eux seuls
près d'un milliard de kilos de polystyrène,
remplissant, de façon stupéfiante, 25% des décharges.
Pourquoi avons-nous ces accumulations fantômes de déchets de polystyrène ?
Pourquoi ne pas les recycler comme beaucoup de plastiques ?
Pour le dire simplement, le polystyrène recyclé est trop cher
et potentiellement contaminé.
Il y a donc très peu de demande pour du polystyrène recyclable.
En conséquence, le polystyrène est considéré comme non recyclable
car il n'est ni faisable ni viable de recycler du polystyrène.
De nombreuses villes américaines ont même passé des décrets
interdisant la production de beaucoup de produits contenant du polystyrène,
y compris les ustensiles jetables,
billes de calage, emballages de plats à emporter,
même les jeux de plage en plastique,
tous ces produits très utiles dans la société actuelle.
La France est devenue le premier pays
à interdire totalement les ustensiles, tasses et assiettes en plastique.
Et si nous pouvions utiliser du polystyrène,
conserver les avantages de ses capacités d'emballage
bon marché, léger, isolant
sans avoir à souffrir des répercussions
d'avoir à s'en débarrasser ?
Et si nous pouvions le transformer en quelque chose d'utile ?
Et si nous pouvions rendre l'impossible possible ?
Mon équipe a émis l'hypothèse
que nous pouvions utiliser le carbone présent dans le polystyrène
pour créer du charbon actif,
aujourd'hui utilisé dans presque tous les filtres à eau.
Le charbon actif fonctionne grâce à des micro-pores
qui filtrent les contaminants dans l'eau ou même l'air.
Nous avons commencé par faire divers tests de chauffage,
malheureusement, il y a eu beaucoup d'échecs.
Rien ne fonctionnait.
En plus du barbecue de mon père qui a pris feu,
la plupart de nos échantillons se sont évaporés
ou ont explosé à l'intérieur de fourneaux chers,
les laissant sales et collants.
Nos échecs nous ont rendus si tristes que nous avons presque abandonné.
Pourquoi continuer à essayer
quand tous les adultes disaient cela impossible ?
Peut-être parce que nous sommes des enfants pas très avisés.
Mais en vérité, nous avons continué car nous croyions cela possible.
Si cela réussissait,
nous aiderions l'environnement et rendrions le monde meilleur.
Nous avons essayé
et échoué
et essayé
et échoué.
Nous étions prêts à abandonner.
Puis, ceci s'est produit.
A la bonne température, avec les bons produits chimiques,
nous avons eu un résultat positif
qui nous a montré que nous avions créé du charbon actif avec du polystyrène.
A ce moment-là, ce qui était impossible
ne l'était plus.
Bien que nous ayons connu beaucoup d'échecs au début,
nous avons su persévérer pour obtenir les résultats désirés.
En plus d'avoir été capables de créer du charbon actif
pour purifier de l'eau,
nous avons pu réduire les déchets en polystyrène,
résolvant deux problèmes mondiaux avec une seule solution.
Cela nous a poussés à aller de l'avant avec notre projet,
faisant plus de tests pour le rendre plus efficace
et le testant en situation réelle.
Puis nous avons obtenu le financement
du programme « STIM en action » d'eCYBERMISSION de la NSTA
parrainé par l'armée américaine
et du prix de l'innovation mondiale
parrainé par XPRIZE.
Nous avons été récompensés
par le prix de l'innovation scientifique américaine
au salon scientifique de Google.
Nous prévoyons, grâce à ces fonds, de breveter notre processus
et de continuer à travailler sur ce projet.
Oui, bien que nous ayons commencé par mettre le feu au barbecue de mon père
et tant échoué que nous avons presque abandonné,
cela valait la peine, en y repensant maintenant.
Nous avons pris un problème dit impossible par tant
et l'avons rendu possible.
Nous avons persévéré quand il semblait que rien ne fonctionnait.
Nous avons compris qu'il n'y a pas de réussite
sans un peu
ou beaucoup d'échecs.
A l'avenir, n'ayez pas peur si votre barbecue part en fumée
car vous ignorez quand votre idée pourrait s'enflammer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)